you know the strangest thing you can ask
someone right now is what are you up to
or what have you been up to have you
have you had someone ask you that yet
hey man what are you up to
why what am I'm up to nothing I'm up to
nothing what there's nothing to do wha
hey man what you been doing nothing
hey hey buddy I'd know nothing do do you
understand I you know I I've realized
one of my buddies is a psycho path or
psycho whatever it is psychopath he's
like hey man what do you been doing huh
oh me oh yeah man I just been you know I
just travel we went to the waterslide
last weekend and um you know we went to
DiMaggio's you know that restaurant
nothing I've been doing nothing the same
thing that everybody has been doing no
matter who you are right now you're
doing I don't care if you are Walter
Disney you're doing nothing even people
that are smoking DMT right now no matter
how hard a hit they take nothing happens
because there's nothing to do except
podcast I guess let's go
[Music]
yep is that same song baby
mmm hello I'm just selling off your
front porch Waldron how could I be so
far oh and my mom is somewhere else but
when I found it our patch up where it's
been hey man what you been up to man now
I'm just floating on the breeze and I
feel I'm full and like these leaves I
must be gonna stop
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my life I can feel it
enough thought it's gonna change
little town live at a time maybe some
tick-tock for me to sell that parking
brake
and let myself
[Music]
and tell you my story
hey man what you been up to nothing
nothing absolutely nothing there's
nothing to do I think like there's
nothing I mean I have been people like
what you been doing well honestly what
I've been doing usual stuff I do really
try not to masturbate or do
self-pleasure do self bust I have been I
have learned I I've learned that I can
cook and then I've learned that I don't
know any good recipes that's what I
learned I learned like okay I'm I'm
willing to cook like I find myself just
making something that's around my
apartment like oh okay I'll have a
little bit of lettuce and oatmeal
oh there could be something you know I
found myself less mixing oh yeah yeah
I'll have a pop-tart and I'll have you
know I have a pop-tart and I'll have two
orange halves or orange you know just
like wild mixes okay I'll have a little
you know some cuts of um London broil
and uh and you know and maybe for babies
snicker and that's the dinner just the
the the connect like things that connect
there that the the it doesn't matter
anymore it you you know before corvid it
was like the the the afternoons
connected to the lunchtime the evenings
connected to the dinner but now we don't
matter the breakfast is connected to the
midnight snack
it don't matter Oh rise and shine you
know I got half a bag of Cool Ranch
Doritos and um and you know a third of a
cup of uh you know baby marshmallows for
you and don't forget to have don't
forget to squeeze uh you know a chunk of
lime in your mouth and and that's it
it's just you know the there's the I'm
just saying that you can have whatever
you want right now and it can be a meal
you don't even have to mix things like
before pre pre corvid you had to mix
stuff oh you want to make a cake you
need to get an egg do an egg in a bucket
do a flour do some milk or some leche
some Mexican milk and do it like that
and do it and mix it up and throw some
sprinkles in it and put on doing oven
and then to do damn you got a cake you
got a birthday you got a complete on yo
you know circle a cake but now don't
matter you want to crack an egg
in your mouth you want to take half a
dram of water a little bit of milk eat a
quarter stick of butter you know high
two packets of um sugar under your
tongue of sugar in the raw BAM son you
know you've had some cake there's just
the the the template is kind of blown
out oh it's lunchtime why don't you have
a freaking porterhouse steak with a
Chobani yogurt
why don't you do you want to peel it a
little do a Chobani daddy do that little
you know how to how to half a
gram of yogurt in your little cousins
jaw and then you know and then beat his
little ass if you have to sorry you know
let him you know don't just hit him like
in the back and like in the fat areas
don't hit him anywhere ever it's could
hurt him what's going on I don't know I
don't I don't it's the dumbest what's
going on
not uh not a Spanish nothing nothing is
going on I've been at home I don't even
know it's out it's nice to not have to
set your alarm clock didn't I know some
of you have children you can't relate to
it but it's nice to not have to set your
alarm you know I don't need an alarm for
anything right now
I don't need I don't it doesn't would if
it's it doesn't matter if it's 11:50
p.m. or 4:00 a.m. I can watch another
episode of shits Creek and then go back
to bed doesn't matter doesn't matter if
it does it does it nothing matters
nothing my what's go what's going on
nothing nothing I'm just trapped playing
with the Devils that are inside of me
that's what I'm doing most of the time I
want to thank you guys for supporting
the cast that's for damn sure that is
for DES that is for damn sure
what's going on I've been I guess I've
been feeling like a lot of things during
this recently I've been feeling like
well I've been taking pretty good care
of myself you know I've been doing a
good bit of um outdoor action running
walking you know I'll pretend like I
lost something in my area or something
go look for it look for a missing animal
look for a you know like oh my cousin's
car got stolen
I'm we know we're looking forward have
you seen it people like nah nah nah but
you keep looking you know just anything
to kind of get out of the house you know
what else I've been rolling out my body
and I know
some people they say you get on the foam
roller if you've seen it it's a it's
like a pipe but it's made out of foam
it's like a foam piping piece like a fat
little foam pipe and you lay your body
on it
and you just ride your body back and
forth on it I mean if this thing could
get pregnant it would get pregnant and
you just slide your body your legs
especially your thighs here your
buttocks here the area between your nuts
and your knees whatever that is leg and
you slide that up and down this some
foam roller and it alleviates your
tension I mean it you'll see a damn
ghost fly out of your ass like it this
thing will loosen the muscle tension
inside of you it really does it just
loosens it all up so I've been doing
that full-body like doing my triceps on
it my bicep like laying on in just sheer
agony just and just I mean till it just
hurts so much man
till just like and it's this big black
pipe kind of thing and it's like it just
feels like it's just I mean just just
taking my muscles virginity you know
just ruse just terrorizing these
really kind of like if you ever seen an
episode of that black
pornography and it's women kind of
getting attacked by big large black you
know penises and penis and it has that
sort of ambiance to it just and just
rolling you're just I mean rolling my
chest is rolling everything out
so I've been doing that what else that's
him and not that there's not you know I
went to the park the other day I look at
some dog people out there with a dogs um
and when I was growing up your boy
Daniel in my neighborhood some of you
guys know about him and some of y'all
don't and he was the kind of dude that
would you know he would uh tell you like
maybe if you were having a licorice
chunk or um if you were having a a bit
of honey candy he would tell you oh
they're poisonous they're poisonous and
you'd spit it out on the table and he
would take it and eat it he was that
kind of man he was a like he was just
second-hand sugar he didn't carry tricky
out of your own sweet and then he would
polish that batch off right in front of
you and um anyway his father had trained
they had a dog
this little disgruntled little dog in
the UH this little I got on if it was
like a beagle or like a damn like an
Australian kind of beagle kind of like a
kind of enough like an Australian kind
of beagle sort of hound but it would um
named muscle was the dog's name and it
would they trained it to kind of I guess
kind of hump or dogs other dogs at
the dog park so we'd go down there they
had this kind of dog and it wasn't
really a dog park back then when I was
growing up it was just a lot of dogs
would meet up usually to eat or to look
at each other and you'd see a dog
walking by or one dog whatever you know
uh you know he would the owner would
paint something on the side of him like
a political slogan or just all kind of
like an animal meet up and
um and they had their little dog a
little muscle and this thing could
I'll be honest it's the only dog I've
ever seen that could run up behind
another dog and jump it it was real so
it had long legs in the front but was
short legged in the back and this thing
could hump like a dam like a speed bump
this thing could hump like a
like an extended cab camel this thing
had that up-down up-down up-down going
and it could run and jump up into the
air and land Weiner Weiner into another
animal and so this little thing it was
like the damn Robin Hood of
really and you'd see it run up and just
jump onto another animal in and they had
trained it to do sex so it was just
baffling man it was just blew my mind
every time we go to like the little dog
meetup and they had you know when little
muscle would show up and this thing boy
you'd see the other owners be like aw
here comes a little muscle man that
little damn Bill Cosby out here this
little thing just not afraid to really
sexualize other animals but what else
what's going on man nothing nothing
what's for breakfast huh uh veal
parmesan sounds good sounds good what
else uh head trick you on that one let's
take some calls man nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three
I've been running I've been trying to
take care of myself physically and I've
been doing a lot of meditation and and I
am let me see here that as my damn lungs
I'm like 45 days I'm not 45 maybe 44
days of no
but I wanted one yesterday man I'm
wanted one I had up I was talking like
an ex-girlfriend Mike's girlfriend and
just man we just kind of got into it and
just made me want a damn cigarette it's
crazy how like relationship
conversations and things like that can
really get my damn could really get the
just get my goiter you know I'm serious
me and that type of stuff can really
just I mean just makes me just I mean
it'll just makes me want to hide my own
penis inside of my ass you know just I
hate that kind of stuff just I don't
hate it but I don't like it man I don't
like that kind of stuff that kind of
stuff just makes me uncomfortable but
life and life's life is up this life is
an uncomfortable thing isn't it
isn't life an uncomfortable thing
sometimes and they don't teach you that
in school they don't have a class that
you think for one hour on a Thursday
they'd had everybody meet in the gym
they would have us meet in the gym for
anything Oh kids are pissing on the
heaters and doing you know big yellow
steam in there every every you know
every afternoon and so they got to have
a convention in the gym tell her we're
gonna smell everybody's dick and nobody
of course I'm everybody's dying laughing
but people playing yellow smoke in there
people playing a little bit of
you know Vietnam a little bit of uh you
know people playing a little bit of
Agent Orange or something in there and
pissing on the thing on the heat on the
here and uh toilet
but whatever man whoo I don't even know
what I'm talking about
welcome to the podcast what's going on
man what have you been up to
there's nothing to be up to that's why
that's why that is why let's get a call
that came in here we go
[Music]
21st birthday we've been together for
about seven and a half years and were
raised 21 I'm 20 but anyways we're big
fans of you damn y'all been together
seven and a half years and you guys
don't even know how old y'all are you
guys are young huh
damn I drink y'all's damn blood huh
homeward he took me to yourself it's on
my birthday this past August and I was
wondering if you could help me out and
somehow send me a video of you saying
happy birthday jury or happy birthday
sterling this is legal name oh hell yeah
there's nothing I love more than
somebody that has a legal name don't you
love that
what's my name my name is Alan but my
legal name is Carondelet yeah my name is
uh Tucker but my legal name is vacuum
Nathan
like hanging vacuum Nathan damn let's
hear more startling let's hear let me
hear more about this little mf'er that
would mean so much to me and he might
his pants I'm only kidding out our
video for you
no no no honey I'm trying to stay off
the pornography and you know that but I
appreciate it homeward
but yeah my number is
let me try them real quick let me try
this young buck and see if we can get
that get him on the line real quick him
I wish him a damn HB he deserves it I
think what have you been doing man
that's what I'm gonna ask him what is
her name Bethenny sorry
you
your call has been forwarded to an
automatic voice-message system
is not available at the tone please
record your message
when you have finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
legal names darlin happy birthday dad
rooster
[Music]
happy birthday dad rule
[Laughter]
what's up Drew's girlfriend this is Theo
von I'm just calling just wanted to say
thank you for the call and for offering
me the opportunity to wish drew sterling
a happy birthday and um and I hope he
lives it up man you guys are in
quarantine I hope you guys make it
happen get y'all a baby get y'all of
something you know buy adopt our little
Dalmatian do something nasty do
something wild or get a baby and put
little black spots on him
get that spot at baby that little uh
Patrick my home was boy that patty maja
you can do it and I love you man I just
want to tell you guys I love you send
this to Drew for me because um you only
left his number on here but a happy
birthday man and keep your head up out
there
and I'd ask you what you've been doing
but nobody's been doing anything so you
gotta be well yeah man a feisty today I
feel that's how I feel I feel feisty I
feel feisty um I just feel I feel fiest
straighted that sort of feeling and I
feel damn Feist Rader brothers nothing
to watch dude there's nothing that
there's nothing to watch there's nothing
let's take some calls that's what we do
have we have each other so let's get a
few calls in here gang brother homework
CEO what up it's your boy Nathan from
Minneapolis dirty Nate over there from
Minneapolis and you know nick swardson
is from over there and he really that
man is really they call him the he
really has uh actually he told me the
other day he has Corona Rio which is
when you have you know fluid stool and
also corvid baby gang on word and
I'm just calling to say thanks I was
just listening to uh one of the episodes
from the other week I think it's called
perspective gadget you got on this
about our items on a sale rack and that
just I don't even know how to
describe how funny that was to me I
started kicking the air I'm by myself
outside my place doing a little American
spirit and cracking up so hard that I
just started kicking the air I have no
idea where oh yeah that o2 dojo bro
that's at o2 dojo we need to start
kicking the air bro
wait till you put the air into a
damn rear naked choke wait till you
start doing that wait till you start
getting to that next level where you
freaking you know what I'm saying you'll
call them up on the top rope and jump on
to nothing and just leg drop absolutely
nothing at all
gang okay from but that's what you
brought to my life so thanks man love
you love you too brother thank you for
the call man thank you for the call out
there getting some vibe and enjoying
yourself and and just feeling something
yeah there's like there's there's no
sports there's no sports so I mean if
some people are stuck in there imagine
if you are a person who has too often it
doesn't work at home and your wife died
and you guys don't spend much time
together it's been like that for years
and suddenly y'all are stuck together
I wonder how these domestics are doing
if anybody out there is an officer of
the law I would love to know if you
could hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three and
let us know if the the amount of
domestics has gone up yeah there's no
sports anything anything anything could
become a sport I mean they're gonna put
you know ESPN one of the famed networks
famed sporting networks they're having
their showing down people you know they
have a Charles Barkley making a
casserole now I mean anything could be a
sport domestic disputes
I wouldn't be surprised if that becomes
you know if they start to make leagues
or a tournament you know like oh damn
you know Tiffany sure beat the out
of Randle last week but it's best two
out of three so let's see how this
shakes out let me do this - let me tell
you also if you're bored in your house
what you have to be you know why because
what you've been up to
- not another mop them up then literally
I fell asleep with half a mouth full of
bugles and I had just went to bed
I just ate half of a carton of frosting
and I'm playing hide-and-go-seek with my
kid and I've been hiding for four hours
and he's never gonna find me because I
drove down the block to the supermarket
parking lot and I'm sitting here in my
car and watching other men sit in their
cars that's why
and speaking of that when I was growing
up they had um you know they had a a lot
of men in adult men I mean not uh not
like real hairy kids I'm talking about
fully adult men a man you could tell he
had a the kind of guy was not afraid to
put up you know half a mouthful of
Copenhagen in between his penis and his
nuts
then take the dip in that way that long
route when I was young a lot of men
different men troubled men men who had
holes in their shirts type of guys you
know older men as well guys like Bryan
Callen who you know I don't know if you
know him or not he's a he kind of he
modeled for a bit he modeled for
actually he he elfin the Shelf is based
on him his body typing and a mythical
youth but a lot of men would go to the
winn-dixie and park out in front of it
and uh cry and stuff in her car and
drinking and it was this was before they
had self-help and all that this before
you could get help for yourself and men
would drive up an errand you know drink
and sit in her truck drink pleasure
themselves some time with a booklet with
a booklet you know a lot of and I
hate to say that word sorry and I should
have told you I was gonna say it and I
didn't I'm sorry I didn't but I'm
telling you right now I'm gonna say it
one more time right now so if you don't
like hearing it don't hear it when I say
it but me and we'll get out there and
get a booklet and touch they touch
their penis and you know keep petting
their own penis until
until something came out of their body
it's a little bit of a jack you know
what I'm saying
that body sauce bruh a little bit of
God's front wash you know what I'm
saying that starter that starter sauce
but with that said um this episode is
brought to you by better help better
help is a real and forthright group that
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist now if you've ever seen any of
my life or heard anything about me you
know I have been to countless hours of
therapy and and I've also experienced
therapy through better help with better
help you can start communicating in
under 24 hours so it's it's not a crisis
line but it is a line where if you feel
a sense of just that you need something
more for any type of mental or emotional
distress you're dealing with that they
can help it's professional counselling
is what it is and there's a broad range
of expertise in their counselor Network
which may not be locally available to
you in your area you can get on better
help you can log into your account and
anytime and send a message to your
counselor and you can say can we can we
chat today can we chat tomorrow you
could text just say I want to check in
about someone struggling with this you
know struggling with that you know
Martha won't let me you know hang out at
the house with my friends or Martha just
bought a coffin and is chiseling my name
into the side of it should I be alarmed
yeah you should
with better help you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
you will never have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help wants
you to start living a happier life today
you know if you treat you having a tough
day you struggling you hit your
counselor up you know hey counselor I'm
struggling but up but up BAM oh yeah
let's chat today at 2 p.m. anywhere you
are you could FaceTime anything
better help want you to start living a
happier life today visit better help
calm slash th e oh that's B e TT ER H
ELP and join the over half of million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for this past
weekend listeners get 10% off your first
month at better help calm slash Theo and
grateful to them for better help oh
let's take another call here as always
the hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three we've got some
responses coming up to the Domino's
pizza delivery guy who had seen his life
hit a real curb and he wanted to
tighten up his ability and and really
get them you know that guy thought he
was just gonna I mean that guy didn't
know if he was about to lock his own you
know just duct tape a damn hot pizza to
the side of his head or what and we got
some ha some stuff for him sorry I'm
I'm on some coffee brought me
honest I've been off coffee for about 10
days maybe 12 probably 10 and that
today bro I had a cup dawg
hmm but I feel like honest I could
reaching him on bud and and and find
something new that's how I mean that's
where I'm kind of coming from at this
moment so this coffee got me shook man
got me shook up brought like a damn
Christmas globe you know and I were one
time I went to India and I bought a
Christmas globe because things are hella
cheap in India I mean like a nickel a
dime a 50 cent and I got a Christmas
globe in there and inside of it it had a
picture of a snowman and he had a little
sign and it said Just Married Christmas
that's what it said on it and that's one
thing I loved about India you you could
get things that and they it up
every time they it up
it would say happy Halloween right and
it would have a picture of the Easter
rabbit and in his basket he would have
like a um he would have like a little
day in his basket he would have like a
basket ball in there and it would say
Merry Christmas you're like why but
that's India bro if you want some real
wild go to India dog they
got it and you could walk as far as you
want in India they don't give a damn if
you want to walk somewhere start walking
dog the cops pull you over where you
going Oh Delhi New Delhi Old Delhi
double/double Delhi Doga and they'll be
like well when when you gonna get there
if I'm supposed to get there in November
like all right good luck do you could
get out of any crime you know I was
opposed to be in Nashville the other day
this past weekend for uh for that comedy
show Friday night and and I'm so sorry
that that didn't happen and uh yeah just
I wish I got to see everybody I miss it
you know I miss being able to be out
there and
and seeing people and I'm glad I'm
having I'm feeling that way I'm glad I'm
you know I'm just missing everybody you
know I miss I just I don't know I mean I
just I just miss everybody
so I guess that's one thing when people
say what have you been doing I guess
I've been missing everybody you know
let's take some other calls that came
here here we go
hey you know my name's Tony from Wichita
Kansas
hey there Tony and Tony is a nickname
also for Anthony or Antonio homeward I'm
just listing your podcasts right now and
you're talking about the seniors not
being able to have prom and all we've
missed and I'm one of those students I'm
a senior this year cancelled prom I
don't know when I'm going to be able to
walk the stage for graduation my
birthday is on April 17th and I was
going to sign at my school to a college
for wrestling and now I can't have any
of that and it's just man it's hard
doing online school being stuck in the
house all day man I love your show okay
gang brother yeah that's I mean I yeah I
mean I can't imagine we talked a little
bit about it last week I can't imagine
that you know you can't you uh you know
you got to sneak around if you want to
touch a titty or do something and at
your age I look I'm gonna say this I'm
gonna tell you you know at your age
there's probably some women you're like
I don't know if I'm really into them but
if they want to mingle touch that titty
baby okay because later in life you will
want to remember touching it even if it
was mediocre you know I remember a girl
over there in um North Carolina and
that's one of the premier 50 states over
there near the East Coast but kind of in
the south kind of people kind of don't
know where it is
and it starts with north even though
it's in the south so it's obviously also
lost but a beautiful place man they got
mountains they got valleys they got all
kind of
and the ones like oh they had a girl
there her breasts felt like a pair of
damn uh diapers really you know
baby diapers and when you squeeze you
ever seen a baby's diaper when it's full
if you get that hot little that bottom
sac on a baby and they fill that thing
up that thing there's nothing more kind
of fun really than seeing a full diaper
hang off a baby's bottom this is
funny you know what I'm saying when I do
that baby is badass that's kind of a
Tony Stewart of babies if you see a
bunch of babies run around and um oval
or a big track or circle or even just
run by you and you see a couple of them
got clean diapers and then that one baby
goes by with that fat bat
caboose bruh and that thing is just you
know that that rump has been chunking
bruh that thing's been front dripping
dog and that diaper is full got damn or
something really you're like oh that's
the Tony Stewart of babies right there
but anyway this lady's breasts were like
that and when you kind of squeeze them
they stayed in the shape you squeeze
them in which is unprecedented really if
you think about that you know really
think about it think about it uh the
titty or something that looks like a
titty okay think about it you got the
thought okay now squeeze it or something
now take your hand off and it stays in
the squeezed shape and you didn't
squeeze hard you squeeze just a decent
amount
you know you squeeze just a Cosi the
normal amount of squeeze a titty would
want and it's
days like that praise God brother but
that's how this lady so and I remember
the next day I had written up there with
a band a group of a group of musicians
were they called this is when I was
living in Charleston South Carolina over
there this band man they let me get on
the stage sometimes and I would wear
small shirts and the shirts didn't fit
me that well because I hit a late growth
spurt in my and but I hadn't really
purchased made any purchases to to you
know really cover myself since the spurt
and um Jesus I'm going off track uh what
I'm telling you is this dude
that if you get a chance bruh go and you
you just you you won't regret it usually
you won't regret reach them for that
opportune hit bruh you won't regret it
man you're not gonna think years later
man
good thing I didn't you know put a
couple dollars in the tank and go over
there and touch a little breast touch
that big front knuckle you feel
me so but anyway man what was your
problem yeah dude I'm sorry you can't go
to prom man that should has
heartbreaking and and that you know not
to imagine being a senior in high school
is you're so excited you know it's your
year may you get to walk around one of
your friends has a beard all of a sudden
you're like damn Jake he's like yeah I
know
oh yeah oh you know things are happening
and one of you you know one of your
friends gets knocked up little Deandra
you're like damn Deandra
just going on in huh yeah well guess
i'ma keep it oh ha ha
Deandra you know people are making
choices one of your and you don't get
that you don't get to see that every day
you don't get that experience man I mean
I am real sorry man it's heartbreaking
bro it's heartbreaking but I think that
there's gonna be others so there's gonna
be some other great experience in your
life that's going to happen because of
this there's gonna be some way that this
shakes out that's gonna be pretty
awesome man
will it be as awesome as your senior
year of high school though I do not know
bro I don't want to lie to you man and
did not have prom think about people not
having prom right now um that's got to
be hectic not having prom there are
people there there's youngsters missing
the prom that's why I said that we
should have Amazon prom you get a box in
the mail it's got a pro hole prominent
in the box
you know it's $13 it's $60 for the
upsell you know you get the you know you
get you get the whole thing in the box
you get a little thing of um lights some
Christmas lights you know you get a
poster it says uh you know a night to
remember or um you know a walk in the
smog or something you get that you know
you get a corset you get up you know you
get a picture of two people eating um
overpriced Italian food you that you get
then you get somebody vomits and for an
extra 13 dollars so that they somebody
vomits in your car an hour later
that's prom that's Amazon prom you know
Tiffany don't have a bra so she got a
borrow ah Janet's you know what a Jan
it's a piece of leg hosiery um you know
uh what is it called um panty one of
them you know uh Nana leg
it looks like like a panty no I'm
talking about they got a tire um what is
that hosiery they got a tie a hosiery
under a breast and they got a borrow
that that's Amazon one of those is in
there you know you get a hit of acid
somebody gave you don't even work that's
in there too that's six dollars do you
got it Amazon prom you get everything
you get that angry parent that shows up
when you making out with you know with a
girl everybody calls big Reno
that's her nickname and you know her mom
comes out yelling and damn Mazda over
there Mazda s 6 or whatever and she
comes out and tries to fistfight you in
the yard because y'all over there
necking you know you get to pretend like
your dates dress looks good even though
she looks absolutely ridiculous
that's prom Ross Amazon prom you get all
that in the box man you get all that in
the box this Mike just broke whatever
its life man but dude I Love You Man and
I'm sorry you know you don't get that
and look I'm a you know you you don't
get that special you don't get to go
over to somebody's house and there's a
keg and some one of your friends
get to alcohol poisoning gets to go to
the emergency room you don't get it you
know it's heartbreaking you don't get to
take photos and then you have to take a
big group photo with a group of people
you don't even freaking know and that
cost you an extra six dollars and
everybody's got acne you don't even I
mean people hit and grow spurts even
somebody starts at the problem they're
five two when they get there a five
seven when they leave you don't even
know what happened to Ernest who
knows bro who knows but I Love You Man
be safe out there
tan this coffee's got me jacked
up
let me tell you this man if you're not
taking care of your crotch an area now's
the time and now really is the time this
episode is brought to you by manscaped
this is quarantine times you're bored at
house you bored at the homestead a
trailer you living in a park and you
bored why not play with your balls are
tighten them up manscaped is here to
make sure your balls are smooth and
classy while you or your partner are
playing with them that's it
touch yourself and touch your beautiful
self you don't want to be touching your
balls and feel like you petting a little
uh a little um you know like a soft soft
kind of nuggety little rat manscaped is
the only men's brand dedicated to below
the waist grooming while you're probably
looking for new things to do what are
you doing man nothing why not make
manscaping part of your routine look
I've trimmed my stuff many times and I
do love the man scape trimmer because
you can't cut in to your body
dude when I was growing up you had to
pull the hair away from your body your
nuts and your wiener and yet it cut it
with a kitchen knife with a blade man
the same blade you used to chisel
something to a tree or to cut
your friend manscaped is forever
changing the grooming game with the new
perfect package 3.0 the third generation
trimmer features a cutting edge ceramic
blade to prevent manscaping accidents
your balls are going to be Nick free
thanks to manscaped they have a
waterproof cordless body trimmer
that's right use it in the shower
subscribe to the perfect package and get
a new replacement blade refill for your
lawn mower trimmer delivered to your
door every three months making sure your
trimmer always stays fresh and clean
fresh 20% off in free shipping with the
code th EO at manscaped com
do yourself a favor
and use the right tools for the job get
20% off and free shipping with code theo
at manscape comm that's 20% off with
Free Shipping at manscape comm use code
Theo
thanks manscape for supporting the
podcast and thank you guys for
supporting manscaped it's a good way to
help support the podcast as well what
else oh I was thinking about this that I
have a prediction that that Hillary
Clinton is going to end up running
against Donald Trump's and here's what's
gonna happen
because Joe Biden's is really I mean
he's disappeared I don't know he just
he's aging quickly it seems like and if
he's not then I believe it's being made
to look like he is right so if he is
physically unable to run which can
happen they the delegates the the
prophets I don't know this part but the
Democratic Party I don't know who I
don't know exactly how but this is true
that the Democratic Party can put up a
new candidate they can just say oh he's
too sick you know he can say I'm too
sick I can't do it I can for whatever
reason and then at the last minute they
can but this is our candidate so I have
a feeling that that's what they're gonna
do that the Democratic Party's gonna
slip Hillary in there the last second
because it takes off the road that's all
that that beat down on the road all that
hard the you know the um all you know
Biden took that he took all that that
her motion he took all the commotion
that was going on and then he kind of
took all the bullets and then Hillary
gonna stroke there at the last second so
I just have a feeling man because if
that that's a true thing like I think
Frank Franklin Roosevelt had
a couple of terms and then he was too
sick he was too sick I think to to run
during like his last term or something
or when he was running for his last term
he was too sick to run and they had a
sub him out they basically sub him out
so you can people can be subbed out and
they don't have to go to like a whole
like everyone doesn't have to vote again
from their party and stuff like that
they just the delegates choose the
delegates choose like okay this is who
we've decided boom so just kind of wild
but that's my predictions man
I predict that that's gonna happen I
just wanted to get that out there um
what else let's get to a couple more
calls here man here we go
yo do it often from cap California hey
Austin thanks for callin brother I got a
little question that since they're
planning on doing back Dean for this
coronavirus let's just say it turns in
the I am legend turns everybody into
zombies if I don't get it do I run for
the hills with my girlfriend or do I
leave her behind and take my little Shih
Tzu puppies Mac and Cooper I appreciate
your input
Thank You Man it's very you know that's
a sad scenario brother and um and I
think uh you know it's hard it's hard
it's hard to choose but you take max and
Cooper you take max and Cooper man and I
wish the three of you guys the best of
luck man I mean imagine you're gonna
make be able to make beautiful tik toks
with those animals let's take another
call man
here we go gang Theo Andrew from Texas
listening to you the past podcast and
you know you've seen a lot of stuff
about how no if you choose to have kids
maybe that's on you if you ain't got
food at home and
I'm supposed to care you I agree with
that but at the same time a lot of
people are out of work right now a lot
of people don't have getting a paycheck
you know so it's like if a lot of people
were living paycheck to paycheck to
begin with I know you know what that's
like and you know a lot of times people
don't have food for their kids you know
past paycheck to paycheck and then and
then now the sudden yeah
they got no job so I think that's just
something to be mindful of when you got
a lot of listeners that uh you know kind
of rely on you for positive influence
and advice maybe you just take it easy
on people a little bit right now a lot
of people are out of work and that's not
that fault you know it's not really
necessarily on them and when the
government shuts it down maybe it's on
the government to picture backup give
people some paychecks that's
right so game brother I appreciate the
Coleman I appreciate the constructive uh
you know not even criticism I wouldn't
call it I would just say I appreciate
your your your thoughts man yeah I think
what about when I was you know and this
is from last episode I remember I was
talking about you know that it's it's
our responsibility like you're your
parent you're your children's government
that if something you know your kids
don't have something that's really and I
don't have children but it is you're
gonna be that your kids look at you as
their government you know yeah I don't
know if I was really saying that I got
you know and maybe I should not
clarified but I think I was saying more
that our government is just like it's
just I just think this is a good time
for us to recognize that we we need to
be prepared you know we need to be
prepared for stuff I mean this past week
I went and bought a bunch of water you
know I went and got extra canned goods I
want to got extra things that I could
have at home to make sure that I'm
prepared
you know the government's just kind of a
system it's just a you know it's
something that that we've created and
yes like we you know we look to them for
support and for like straw some you know
to keep things structured but when they
start to break down like you know we're
gonna be left with ourselves if the
government breaks down completely we're
gonna be left with ourselves and I think
that's really scary to think I'm sure
it's way scary if you have children you
know because you grow you know we've
we've we've become accustomed to a
society that you know we're able to you
know we have a job because the job
exists because of the markets and the
capitalism and you know it's all and and
then that job gives us a paycheck and
we're able to provide for our families
but I think I was just saying more that
that that system is it's just a you know
it's a system that we've been really
blessed with here in America that we're
really fortunate to have and as scary as
it is that that that's that's just a
it's just a system and it's just a
structure and it's and it could it could
fall apart you know it could fall apart
and then at that point we're gonna be
responsible completely responsible for
ourselves so yeah I don't think I was
saying as much like oh you know like you
know like if you if you have to work
paycheck to paycheck right now that you
know that you're up or there's
anything wrong with you or you know like
it that that's
Jesus Christ I don't know why don't I do
something different for to make my life
okay but um I don't know man I don't
know talking about dude I don't know I'm
talking about well okay do not know what
I'm talking about
I'm just saying that we got it we got to
look out for ourselves you know we
really have to and it's probably really
scary if you have children but we have
to look out for ourselves we got to try
our best to and I think that this is a
reminder in a way that that there's a
whole other system that's going on
that's just a system of like existing
and and this makes that kind of like you
know we were in such this comfortable
hammock of
society that we live in of this
structure were really it really showed
you this how lucky we are to be able to
navigate within this kind of comfortable
structure where the where there are
programs for if we can't work or we
can't survive that there's programs in
place to help us but then also this kind
of perks up that other side of me that
that animal side that's like well what
if that goes away what if something
happens am I going to be able to take
care of myself do I have have I started
to think of what my plan would be and
maybe that kind of thing alone is just a
is just too dark of a thought to really
present so but I hope you're doing well
man I hope you're taking care of you and
your kiddos out there it sounds like you
know that your family is one thing
that's first and foremost on your mind
and and I think that that's real
commendable man gang brother um we had a
caller last week a fella that called any
young buck and he was having issues he
was doing dominoes in delivering um hot
pie and we've all had it you know we've
all had a little bit of Domino's and oh
and one thing I don't know if you knew
this about Domino's somebody sent me
this DM the other day and told me this
but Domino's Pizza used to have a
character called the know Wade and
that's not a racial slur or anything
that's a it's like a cartoon it was like
a dirty cartoon boy that you know was
sneaky and was kind of a tag and I got a
I think her he would wanted to be
Italian it was like a wannabe Italian
and he would attack um he hit on the
commercial for Domino's this character
the noid Noi D and again that's not any
type of a race thing and as a that's
what they called him he would attack the
delivery people or something he would
mess up the order and so the pizza was
going to get there late but Domino's
they said that
we guarantee that won't happen your
pizza will be there in 30 minutes
and you got to understand this was
unprecedented for somebody to say from
the time you call our shop 30 minutes
later we're gonna have food at your
doorstep dog that's gangster dog post
mace don't even guarantee that how
it makes don't get post may say could be
now could be 70 minutes dude I had a
lady one time she was driving her over
got hit got an accident got taken off an
ambulance my said like three hours
because she been at the hospital for so
long everybody gone up to three hours
this lady had not dropped off my Carl's
juniors and this I don't know if she
died or what bro but that
you know I mean it's a risky game out
there when you peddling goods like that
but let me tell you about this the no
wait was this little character and it
was big he had a video game he had big
stuff and dominoes blew it up at that
moment they had pizza in 30 minutes so
the noid though there was a guy let me
tell you what happened so the no wait
here's what happened On January 30th
Kenneth Lamar noid a mentally ill man
who thought the ad campaign was a
personal attack on him entered a
Domino's restaurant in Chamblee Georgia
armed with a 357 gang bruh so you know
the on him well and he held two
employees hostage for over five hours
can you imagine that can you imagine
first of all you freaking working at
Domino's and his second of all the dude
rolls over 357 and held you hostage
actually probably it's probably best cuz
you're still on the clock and you don't
you can't make any pies I mean I guess
you could but the guy might get Pez I
guess it's up to him it doesn't say if
he ordered any pies around it just says
he held two employees hostage for over
five hours after telling the employees
that dominos owner Tom Monaghan had
stolen his name because his last name
was knowing n o ID he forced them to
call Domino's headquarters and demand a
hundred grand and a white limousine as
getaway transportation would an idiot
but you know how hard it is to hide in a
way in a white limousine very hard bro
unless you hide it like I don't know
where you'd hide like in a milk fat like
in a milk area
[Music]
after offering to exchange one hostage
for a copy of the widow's son which I
get a son book the noid reneged on his
offer after a police brought him the
book noid eventually became hungry and
forced the employees to make him two
special pizzas respect man respect while
annoyed ate the pizzas with his gun in
his lap the hostages escaped no heed
surrendered to the police shortly after
after the incident police chief read
Miller told reporters he's paranoid noid
was charged with kidnapping aggravated
assault doesn't say he assaulted
him extortion and possession of a
firearm during a crime I wouldn't call
going to domina as a crime that's kind
of judgmental he was found not guilty by
reason of insanity gang bro no we'd
spent time in a mental institution but
committed suicide in 1985 2m this
incident has been insinuated to have
caused Domino's pizza to discontinue
advertising using the noid as their
mascot Wow so there you go that's
everything that happened with annoyed
and thank you to the young man that sent
me sent me a DM and told me that Oh what
else man what else have I been doing
dude do it nada same thing you've been
doing let's get through this episode man
oh but some a young fella called and he
has some issues with delivering
delivering pies and I want to you know
some man called in with some responses
and I want to share some thoughts uh
that they wanted to give you young buck
here we go hey Shawn callin from
Gulfport Mississippi I just wanted to
send some advice to that young man
called ed and said he was 19 years old
I'm working for Thomas Murphy delivering
high and didn't feel like he had
direction a little to say brother look
you're 19 you're not supposed to have a
direction but you have a job and you're
a productive member of society
you're not laid up on your mom's couch
smoking dope you're doing the right
thing you're headed in the direction
don't worry brother they'll come
together keep doing what
you do and being productive man that's
what it's all about as long as you've
got a little scratch in your pocket you
paying your taxes you're 100% adult man
so keep doing you brother and keep up
the good work trust me man you're young
your life will shape up just stay out of
trouble and keep on a straight path
gang brah I like that message man that's
a good message it got a little anti-drug
at the end with the key post a on a
straight path but before that 100% man
yeah productivity if you stay productive
all you're gonna make is more
productivity let's say there's no the it
doesn't add up any other way if you stay
productive you're gonna produce and all
that's gonna do is create a create
opportunity you know it reminds me of
this fella in our neighborhood growing
up this boy named Robbie and he was real
jacked and he had beautiful hair goddamn
I mean strawberry blonde did he's
probably one of the finest he was a man
but he would have he would have he
qualified he would have qualified as
probably one of the hotter women in our
neighborhood he was you know he was just
jacked he had big old he didn't have to
him and he had it you know he was
voluptuous to be strong as a man but he
had big his arms look like that damn
titties in him just stronger and and he
worked at a grocery store by the
winn-dixie he worked by the place where
people would go cry over there
masturbate and you know kind of spend
time you know before they had mental
health and he worked in there I think he
was stocking shelves at the beginning
and by the end he worked there for a
while and then by the end he was a
manager and then I think he was a
district manager and then he started his
own business he got out of that business
but got started two or three of his own
companies and I went and visited a fella
not long ago and he lived in a dam I
mean a huge beautiful home and like the
nicest neighborhood anywhere in our area
and he just it just show he just he
stayed productive that's all I'm saying
you know he stayed really productive um
let me pull here's another couple calls
that came in about that same thing
brother here they go
hey do my name Jefferson from Denver
Colorado calling in a felon the dude
couldn't get his thoughts together but
we got enough to info out of him that I
wanted to kind of share something with
him he's 19 years old he feels like a
loser
cuz he's at Domino's and doesn't know
what he's doing Thomas are you 99% of
the people on this planet at 19 years
old don't know what they're doing and at
23 years old I started working at
Domino's myself and still didn't know
what I was doing that 23 you know I am
now 36 I'll be 36 here in a couple days
and I'm doing quite well for myself and
I'll started out with Domino's and I
still don't have a degree you just have
to be not afraid to take leaps and push
forward at all times sometimes the power
because you're completes and where
you're at and you don't want to take the
leap to Matthew you know that's the
things you have to do once you get older
so my doing myself you know you're
younger playing pieces that Domino's I'm
doing a whole lot man and trust me I'm
doing pretty well for myself nowadays
gang there you go and that's a fellow
right there that sold pies to adults and
children and he's doing well you hanging
in there and staying productive you
can't there's just there's no way to
really lose I don't think if you stay
productive man there's no real way to
lose man
dude I remember I worked at a place
called BJ's pizza read Annie and this
was a real this was a real you know
beautiful place they had pies in there
they had a little bench to sit on when
you walked in sigh - it was nice and um
and one thing I really missed or one
thing I loved they had a soda machine
had everything Pepsi mister they had
sprite orange
that's when you knew you had at least
we're working at a decent shop they had
two orange soda not just the regular
but anyway um and this place was
called BJ's dude blowj I mean it's
anybody thinks BJ's they think blow jobs
that's a given who asks seventy people
if I see BJ's what do you think of 65
people gonna say blow jobs but this
place they said it meant Black Jacks
nobody's thinking that dawg
nobody's thinking Black Jacks dude
unless you had a picture of three black
guys on the side and they all had a
shirt on that said jack on then I could
see that you know but this didn't have
that it was just a arm it's at BJ's
Pizza and the pizza was actually it was
good but it was up as well
because I don't even know the meat was
real questionable had little balls of
meat
and that was what kind of meat we had if
they wanted ham they got the kind of red
balls and if they wanted burger they got
the little brown balls and dude we had
one pie you were at the end you
splashed a little hit of beer on
top of it people loved it like it just
you know anyway I was working in the
oven was always burning people and they
found human hair in the oven but uh but
before that you know we worked over
there and I had a mop and everything
branagh was crazy and we would get
high and sneak a handful
of pudding bra during during the shift I
go over there and and put my
hand in that pudding and go eating in
the bathroom by myself but uh but what
I'm saying to you man is that and Here I
am you know 2025 you 23 years later and
I'm you know and I'm doing a totally
different trade so that's what I'm
telling you to man is you know a lot of
people I think you know you could start
somewhere and you could end up somewhere
else but I never stopped working I never
stopped working man you know I
definitely I wasn't always as productive
I'm
my time off but I feel like I've always
had a job of some sort okay
best of luck to you though man obviously
people care and they wanted to send in
some messages and we actually got a few
more than that but I believe those are
the two that I can find right here we
got one other call that came in and it
was a response to a gentleman who called
a couple weeks ago his son as an
asthmatic and I want to play this call
getting yo Co say just watching 2
episode 2 69 I just heard that guy : as
kids got asthma something I just wanted
to mention you any of you can say
something about the sort of stuff in
there
ya know well sorry to interrupt you um
and asthma some people don't know if in
a pass what if in a past life your son
was a you know a fish or a water snake
then you have to think that I mean then
it wouldn't it's not shocking that he's
not the best land creature that he
doesn't have he's not as equipped here
if you if you believe in that sort of
thing that someone could be something
and then re re you know be readmitted in
the society of something else so there's
always there's other levels to it all
gang brother let's here uh let's hear
more onward so I just wanted to mention
you maybe you can say something an
episode of something they get the word
know through and somehow you guys
contact and so there's a breathing
exercise called wim HOF breathing
there's a moderator on that Facebook
group for Windows that actually
especially cured his asthma with this
breathing exercise so you know I don't
know for certain if it's gonna work but
it definitely works for this guy but
yeah just wanted to mention it to get
that info to them so they can check it
out all right now gang brother thank you
yes sir there's an opportunity right
there if you have asthmatic or you have
some breathing issues you know don't
have the ability to breathe well hit
them up bro check out their that
Facebook group and you might be able to
find a little bit of solute
in there let's take another call that
came in right here man ninety five six
six four nine five zero three hey Theo
this is Jacob down here in South Florida
what's up Jacob in South Florida they
just um well not so far but in
Jacksonville that it's opened the
beaches back up to humans and man I
literally thought about flying over
there that's how much I really just want
to go get in the water
gang brother homeward I heard your
episode this week and that kid who
called in working at the Domino's who
was kind of upset about where he was in
life it kind of reminded me of my own
situation you know I went to college for
a little bit for the same thing for
music it didn't work out for me I was
eighteen nineteen just delivering pizza
slinging them pies at Papa John's oh
yeah the module pause at Papa John's and
that's a risky pas to deliver that's
them racial pies you know Papa John do
you drop the pie off and it somebody
graffiti the n-word or the l-word inside
of it you know somebody graffiti you
know somebody writes ki ke you know
somebody pulls up a piece of pizza and
they somebody wrote ki ke under it you
know or uh somebody draws a picture of a
Chinese boy on the front jumping off a
building you know you have all kind of
that just unnecessarily
heartbreaking really uh so yeah imagine
that not only say the pies late they get
there too late they open the box they're
also suddenly they're racially offended
you could get gun down over there
in Inglewood bro gang man let's
hear more from pizza slinging them pies
at Papa John's I went from working at
Papa John's I moved across the country I
was working for the mentally disabled
for a few months praise God brother that
was interesting then went worked at a
machine shop doing CNC machining making
gun parts all kinds of crazy like
that
to him then I moved back across the
country back home to Florida now I work
at the
property manager doing inspections of
houses and that's definitely sounds like
somebody that's hiding bodies
bro
gang Oh word sir so for that kid
just keep moving forward man you don't
have to have any kind of experience if
you nail that interview if you're
confident you can basically do whatever
you want I don't really know how to do
but I've had all these jobs and
it's worked out so far so uh keep your
head up brother and keep doing your
thing okay gang brother Thank You Man
thank you for the call and thanks for
thinking of somebody else you know
thanks for thinking of that boy you know
you know one thing I've struggled with
recent I just just too much thinking to
myself just too much man you know too
much I'm own head and really the
solution to that is others other people
make you feel good they really do you
know if you're sick of yourself man if
you are sick of yourself nothing will
make you feel better than helping
somebody else and even man when I help
somebody else sometimes I it's hard for
me there's something inside of me
sometimes that makes me you know like I
had a friend that was working and
recently they couldn't work because of
the virus him so I thought you know I'll
pay him anyway they can't work I'll pay
him anyway and uh and one week I even
paid him more than what our original
agreed on amount and it's crazy man
because I was okay doing it and then it
still bothered me for a couple days
after like this greedy part of me was
like man why'd you why'd you do that you
know and it's funny cuz it's not even it
wasn't even like a part that was like
attached to my heart or anything it was
just like why did you do that you know
why what why I don't know I can't even
figure out exactly what I was upset
about like what about it upset me
but there was just there's just a part
of me that just was I don't know just
like why did you give that why'd you
give them extra money why'd you give
extra why'd you and I'm not saying that
that's how I I'm happy that I did I'm
happy that you know I'm not trying to
brag on myself or anything like that I'm
just thinking because we're all doing
that right now we're all helping out
where we can I'm just trying to think
about there's there's just that little
part of me that sometimes will flare up
man why'd you do that you know why and
that's the devil man that's the dark
archery that's the dark art artistry
that's in us that's in the world it's
that little thing it's that little
tapping on your shoulder a
bro why'd you do that you know that
little part of me that wants to
I don't know just I don't know it's just
the dark arts man it's that thing that
it's that part of me that wants to not
be helpful or not be loving I don't know
what it is man and it's it's almost
impossible to really kill that off
completely it's just impossible you know
I don't know what I'm talking about man
let's take a call right here here we go
hey yo field my name is Greta from
Canada hey Brett what's up man I would
love to know if some people from
different countries want to hit the
hotline I want to know how they're
surviving around the world man I've been
thinking a lot about that how they
surviving over there in Guam via Guam
Scotland Ireland Canada you United
Kingdom okay Spain if you're from
another country and you got the
opportunity to let us know let us know
just how it's holding down over there
because there's a lot of reports online
you know I mean every day they're like
Italy has the most Italy this something
this you know China the Chinese are
lying you know it's all just like all
kind of jibber-jabber ohm word I just
want to let you know that yesterday was
one year sober completely sober for me
no alcohol no drugs and I owe a lot of
it to you but I almost of it to myself
for keeping in there and with that grind
when I say I owe a lot of it to you it's
because you just have that positive
attitude and outlook on everything and
just watching you and watching how you
interact with people makes me want to do
the same but in my own way so uh yeah I
just have to subscribe to say thanks to
you man for just for being there man
okay you be good to yourself
thanks gang bro thanks man thank you
thank you for the nice words man one of
my favorite things you said you said I
got a I want to thank you but I really
want to thank myself man good for you
good for you man good for you thinking
about thank just thank just recognizing
you did this for yourself you know you
didn't give up on yourself man because
that's a hard battle to fight you know
fighting the the battle of addiction in
the Battle of you know of that dead that
shoulder devil you know he'll take your
dander from put it in a damn line and
show it to you say dang don't you want
this now you know what just having that
I don't know man just that's awesome I'm
real real happy for you I'm really happy
for you bro you know that and that must
feel good to not just not have given up
that productivity man to just not give
up congratulations brother
that's beautiful dude we did a lot man
we did a lot in this call let's uh let's
take let's well in there man well in
there for today a lot of great calls
have come in and yeah I'm feeling kind
of jacked up today man I don't
know I'm trying I'm just staying busy
and stuff but I'm just feeling kind of
jacked up you know I just kind of angry
at myself I guess and yeah I guess I
don't know sometimes a lot of this yeah
oh no I think sometimes fear just
sindelle it slips in like I don't know
what I'm doing you know I'm gonna mess
everything up or I'm gonna
[Music]
and then my brain will tell me oh well
there used to be a time when you knew
what you were doing and I don't know if
that's true but that's my brain tell me
I my brain will play that card remember
when you used to know what you were
doing so then I start to get upset at
myself because uh I'm like damn I used
to know but that might not even be true
you know my brain makes its own cards
like we agreed there was a certain deck
and then my brain has just been making
cards of its own and it uses them
sometimes and and it's just uh it's
tough man it is it's tough it's tough
and I know a lot of people are going
through things and a lot of people are
struggling and in different ways and um
and you know that gentleman said it best
right there you know to be good to
yourself and just try and be loving and
you know everything will be okay
everything is okay you know everything
is okay and and I'm grateful Brom
grateful to be here today you know
man what's going on man not nothing is
going on I talked to my niece earlier
that made me feel good you know I talked
to my brother this week hung out with
Mike's girlfriend the other day and we
made a puzzle and that was very nice you
know we just had a nice simple time and
you know I'm grateful to have people in
my life that love me even though I feel
like I haven't always been the best
person and and that's interesting how in
loving somebody there's so much
forgiveness in love you know
it's such a you know when somebody
really loves you man that really really
loves you they are they're really
they're forgiving all the things that
you have done even if they don't even
know what they are really you know when
somebody just loves you just really it's
just a rare it's a rare thing isn't it
isn't it ray or think about it when you
ask somebody how many times in your life
have you been in love and they say oh
maybe once maybe twice um people say
never but you know what to think to
think of how long we stay alive and and
the things that we do and and how many
times you been to the grocery how many
times have you felt sorry for yourself
or how many times have you you know
fallen over while you was reaching for
something
hundreds bruh that all those answers
could be hundreds a thousand maybe but
when somebody says how many times you've
been in love you know you say man once
maybe twice or how many times you love
someone just unconditionally you know
you know maybe never man when I said I
don't think about that one I don't know
if I ever have but it's just so rare
that when you think about the time we
spend here and then when you think about
man how many times I've loved someone
for all a year at all how this how what
a rare thing it is you could spend a
year panning for gold you're probably
probably find twenty golds twenty items
of gold but still you might only fall in
love twice in your life three times I
mean it's just love just it's a powerful
thing
it's powerful to say to somebody man you
know I love you I love you no matter
what I don't think I've ever done that I
think my love is always I love you until
or I love you but or I love you as long
as or I'm gonna really love you when you
know it's hard it's hard man being alive
is interesting it's an interesting
interesting journey all right thank you
guys for supporting the podcast support
our advertisers better help and
manscaped I hope everybody's doing well
appreciate you listening some weeks are
tougher than me for me than others I'm
grateful to have a job you know and I
hope you guys are doing okay you know I
hope that uh that you're not being too
hard on yourselves you know there's a
lot going on there's a lot of sticky
stuff out there so just stay out of the
glue you know but but stay in the honey
you feel me be good yourself and you
guys deserve it okay
[Music]
this is Bishop gone with anything you
want
[Applause]
[Music]
we approach to a papery on the TV
me
[Music]
this reminds me a little bit of wise for
a panic this song
we're the bright light